dude i got this [ __ ] it's actually just  it's like got a nice neck do it i put it  on you know what this is this is the gap  balenciaga he's easy i know i got it i  got like an airbender do you know what i  do  this is a [ __ ] guess what size it is  that's a medium double xl this is a  small  and that's why i [ __ ] with belontiaga  because i walked in there i what do i  wear small small i wear wow i got to  start wearing this stuff yes  that's why i go there i want to be like  i'm i'm in the petite section  i don't know no that's exactly what i  tell you chris  when i went in the store  bro i made sure they knew this i went i  left i went i'm going to leave with my  mediums have a good day yeah i like that  i wear a medium that's why i stopped at  dxl yeah watch like a gsm  you know they have like seven xl excel  stories so i come in and go  where's the small area  uh i'll say something embarrassing i  used to have an endorsement deal with uh  big and tall